انظر إلى الأشياء التالية التي يقولها Simchat Hativat
كافر على القناة 14 انتبهوا نحن قادمون
إلى كيبوتس بيهاري واسمها، لحق بي اثنان آخران
الصور المركزية في قتال الخباز القاسي
العدو هو أحد رؤوس أموال الأطفال الذين هم في الخارج حقًا
لأنه لا يوجد شيء آخر تم ذبحه ببساطة
اقتلهم بالداخل ترى منزل الأطفال
ثمانية ثمانية أطفال ثمانية ثمانية أطفال
ميت وصورة أخرى لفتت انتباهي هي التي رأيتها
تخرجت جانيا زاخارونا لاباركا شيم من كيبوتس باري
أنني أرى الرقم محفورا على يدها، أنت
تقول إنها مرت بالمحرقة في أوشفيتز وفي النهاية
الموت في كيبوتس في مدينتي ليس شيئًا ينطبق عليك حتى
أستطيع أن أفهمه، ثمانية لم يقتلوا
يوضح الأطفال في مون في باري أنه لا يوجد متحدث لباري
في باري، ستشاهد امرأة تدعى جانيا المزيد من الأشياء
الذي يقول منذ وقت ليس ببعيد أيضًا أنه شخص جزء من ظل هو هنا
حتى الأطفال والرضع الذين تم القبض عليهم على حبل الغسيل
حقا في سطر واحد التحويل صعب جدا
عندما رأيت ذلك، صدمتني أيضًا، أليس كذلك؟
افهم بالضبط ما تراه أمام عينيك
هل هي صورة أم أنها حقيقة؟
من الصعب جدًا جعل التحدث بالبوسكيلا أمرًا سهلاً
حول حدث يفترض أنه في كفار غزة ولكن إلى كفر غزة
لقد أوضح منذ فترة طويلة أن هذا الحدث ببساطة لم يحدث بالمناسبة
قال الأشياء التي قيل له أنها لم تحدث وبعد ذلك
قالهم مرة أخرى في جولة للصحفيين الأجانب
الذي وصل إلى مكان الحادث وانتبه إلى ما يقوله المتحدث
وضعت شرطة الإعلام الأجنبي ذلك مؤخرًا
ليف، هذا لم يحدث أيضًا، ثم حدثت أشياء كثيرة
فظيعة وقاسية وأفظع ما يمكن القيام به
تجاه البشر في السابع من أكتوبر من أجل ماذا
قال ميكي روزنتال مثل هذه الأشياء التي لم تحدث
أعتقد أن حجم العداء يزيد
حماس وكأنها بحاجة إلى التسلح وكأن ذلك غير كاف
مثل ولكن ماذا يخترع الناس الجادين
اختراع هذه الأحداث هو الجواب
ربما وضعوها على أنها إشاعة وربما هم هذا غير ذلك
وأهم ما يمكن قوله في هذا السياق
الساحة ليست عسكرية فقط وليست سياسية فقط
وسائل الإعلام بشكل رئيسي ولست متأكدًا من أنها ليست كذلك
الأهم بالنسبة لرئيس وزرائنا، بالمناسبة
وفي ذلك الوقت، نشر اتحاد الإنقاذ القصة
الوهمية أن الطفل
لقد ولد طاهرًا، لكن نعم، سمعت أيضًا شهادة
أحد الضباط يُدعى إليور ليفي، سأعود
إليكم في هذا الأمر لأن الإرهابيين قد عادوا بالفعل
ولهذا السبب نتحدث عنها كثيرا
وهي تبدو وكأنها سجل أسبوعي إلى حد ما، ولكنها ضرورية
اعرض أيضًا الصور واليوم تلقينا صورًا أخرى
ما يحدث هنا في هذه الصور هو أن حماس على وشك العودة
على الفور إلى جميع الأماكن التي يقوم جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي بتطهيرها منها لماذا
حصل اليوم تبادل كثيف لإطلاق النار في حي الرميل
نفس الحي الذي احتلته إسرائيل وطهرته منذ فترة طويلة
يقع مستشفى الشفاء في نفس الحي ولكن بدلاً من ذلك
وأخرى في منطقة أخرى وللتحلية من منطقة مخيم جباليا
وحدث أيضًا تبادل كثيف لإطلاق النار اليوم بعد شاتزل
وقد قام بالفعل بتطهير هذا المعسكر واحتلاله كما ذكرنا
شنق أينما ينسحب جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي أو يخفف قواته
له نرى على الفور حماس والجهاد
ويدخل الإسلاميون في فرق متفرقة
وهذا سيشهد مرة أخرى على اليوم التالي للحرب
وعلى يشوف وتيب اليوم خلال المراجعة الأمنية
وتبادل الصراخ بين الوزراء وبينكم مع المتنصتين
الجديدة من المناقشة لذلك كانت هناك مدرسة دينية
كانت مضطربة عندما بدأت بالفعل بمراجعة أمنية لـ
البطل ولد ليوزير كل اسبوع تقريبا والبطل
يشرح ثوليدو هذا الأمر للوزراء اليوم
أن الحرب قد انتقلت إلى مرحلة أخرى قد لا يتصورها أحد
في بعض أجزاء من الجمهور بطريقة معينة ولكن
هذا ليس هو الحال، دعونا نرى ما سيحدث هناك في المراجعة
وهذا الوزير حاييم كاتس يرد على كلام
ويقول توليدانو إن هناك شعورًا بعدم وجود حرب يا الوزير
تجيبه ميشال شكلي بأن هذا هو دورها أيضًا
لقد ولدنا لترتيب مشاعر أوري السكتة الدماغية العاشرة
أوري ستراك الذي جاء ومعه عدد من الأسئلة المكتوبة
ويخبر جنرال توليدانو أن المحاربين يقولون ذلك عندما
عند عودتهم من الميدان، لا يشعرون بهذا الإحساس
النصر ويحتاج إلى أن يشرح لهم المزيد عن الدبابة
شيكلي بمجرد أن يدخل نتنياهو الغرفة ويتحول إلى جلطة
وأقول لها، ها هو المستوى السياسي، لقد وصل اسمك
اسألوه، في الواقع فإن الوزراء يزعمون أن هناك
نوع من الفجوة بين القصص في الاقتباسات هم
نتلقى من الرتبة العسكرية وما يحدث في الميدان
لأن التكنولوجيا الإسرائيلية هي القاطرة التي تسحبنا
هيا وهو أيضًا الشخص الذي سنقوله عندما ننظر إليه
وعلى التوقعات التي تعرض على الوزراء عند تحديثها
يقولون ميزانية الدولة الاسبوع الماضي
التكنولوجيا الفائقة هي أكبر خطر على التوقعات أي
ونحن نرى الآن في التكنولوجيا الفائقة بشكل عام في العام الماضي
على خلفية سلسلة من الأحداث العالمية أيضًا
محلي ولكن عندما تنظر إلى بيانات
ويرى كبير الاقتصاديين في وزارة الخزانة أن الاستثمارات في مجال التكنولوجيا الفائقة
الإسرائيلية في الربع الأخير من عام 2023
كانت حربنا الأولى منخفضة الشكل
أقل بكثير من أدنى مستوياتها التي كانت هنا في العقد الماضي
عدد المعاملات منخفض جدًا وبالطبع هو كذلك بالفعل
تتعلق بالحرب بالنسبة لي وقد تهز الحياة أيضًا
ومع ذلك، فإن الوضع الاقتصادي لنا جميعًا مخيف
شكراً جزيلاً